morgen mittag oder auch guten abend
nicht bei mir ist es gerade guten morgen
hallo hier ist wieder einmal wanne wie
geht's ich möchte heute etwas testen und
zwar habe ich gestern einen kommentar
unter einem instagram foto bekommen
welches ich nicht so fand ich bleibe
euch das mal hier einmal ganz kann ich
nicht mehr die schwierigkeiten aber
nichts zu verdienen
da kann aber auch zwanziger reaktion von
der computer geladen war es verteidiger
hat die gleiche funktion die langen
leben mitbekommen
lasst mich dazu eine sache auf jeden
fall zuerst sagen wenn ich keine videos
machen würde
die auch nichts zum anschauen das heißt
diese kette beginnt nicht mit dem klick
die kette beginnt mit dem dass ich ein
video produzieren und ins land anschauen
könnt und nicht da habe ich dann geld
verdienen
und ja das prinzip verstehe ich auch und
das ist auch super ich finde es toll
dass ich immer den videos anschaut also
ich würde ich schaue man im feld ist
offen
und dann habe ich das ganze so auf
twitter gepostet und mich so ein
bisschen darüber aufgeregt
beziehungsweise heidmark ist meine
meinung dazu gesagt und darauf dass
kommentar von zu sie gelesen nicht jeden
tag wurden
keine angst das ist voll die witzige
idee aber ich kann ja nicht auf alles
antworten weil der tag hat sondern
wirklich 125 stunden aber dann dachte
ich mir bisschen was probieren das mal
auf heute an diesem sonnigen schönen tag
antworte ich auf alles was meine
zuschauer mir schreiben schicken naja
ich rede hier halt auf alles entweder
mit nike oder mit dem kommentar haben
wir wollen mal schauen wie so ein tag
aussieht in dem ich das mache kurzem
einer tagesplanung heute ist nicht viel
ich muss nur zu studio 71 und meine
videos schneiden ich bin sitz aus super
dass ich ein ganzes intro ungeschminkt
aus dem bett gemacht hat es ist jetzt
neu nur sieben mal schauen wie viele
nachrichten und so ich bis jetzt
bekommen habe ich zähle auch wirklich
nur die nachrichten von heute den 26
februar gut dass ich für dieses
experiment mit babys beautycase
glücklich
3000 jahre später ich habe gerade
herausgefunden wie man auf dem iphone
die bildschirmaufnahme startet also das
nächste mal bin ich leiten werde und
kommentieren werde
werdet ihr das dann auch live sehen was
auch passieren muss dennoch nicht
instagram ausgecheckt und twitter könnt
ihr auch sich noch jemand gemeldet haben
aber ich muss mich jetzt erstmal spielen
doch bevor man den tag erst richtig
starten kann muss man voll sein heiliges
lama grüßen hallo heiliges lama
geheiligt werde dein name deinen fell
komme wie auch im himmel zum segen
kaffee bitte ignoriert wie unheimliches
hier ist ich hatte ein paar sehr
anstrengende tage
zusammen mit anderen so es ist jetzt
fast eine stunde später und mal gucken
ob es auch auf youtube neue kommentaren
gibt beziehungsweise auch auf instagram
und twitter denn damit noch gar nicht
geschaut
ja es gab neue kommentare auf youtube
macht einen graben burger pizza burger
was ist denn ein graben burger pizza
burger ich kenne alle süßigkeiten aber
die umfassend das ekligste grüne kannte
ich nicht ich liebe die uhus ins gras
ich mag welche waschen da fühle ich mich
immer so erwachsen ich mich auch anderen
würde ich mal sagen abzuarbeiten
das ist die jagd als beim letzten video
und ich liebe sie
die ist wirklich super ku guck ich muss
wirklich schneiden gehen weil sonst wäre
das alles nix ne also auch kommentare
beantworten und schneiden und so und
youtuber sein
[Musik]
so ich bin jetzt bei studien 70 und
schnell ein video und es ist 11 uhr 12
und zeit mal wieder auf etwas zu
reagieren
wie schmeckt das orangenmarmelade sind
wird schon fertig und bestimmt geil
[Musik]
prosieben kann zu besingen okay dann mal
weiter schneiden so kleine pause vom
schneiden ich muss nämlich auch ein
erster gramm foto heute posten
das heißt nachdem ich das gepostet haben
wird es super spannend weil ich dann
ganz viel zu beantworten habe bzw
je nachdem wie viele kommentare ich
bekommen habe ist bei mir zum glück
nicht so vieles ich glaube andere
youtuber haben da viel mehr zu tun wenn
sie auf alles reagieren würden jetzt
bekommt er ein kleiner exkurs da sind
wie ich meine bilder bearbeite ich
benutze die app sieht also erst mal
machen wir das gegen hier so ein
bisschen heller ein bisschen dunkler
schwer trafen dann mut und schon habt
ihr so bearbeitet wie vanessa das
bearbeitete heute ein wunderschöner tag
die sonne scheint ich bin super happy
und eine freundin hat mich wohin gefragt
ob ich mir die auch philipp poisel
konzert gehen möchte spontan und ich
gehe wollte mit ihr ausfälle präsent
sind und ich freue mich sehr ich feiere
die musikkapelle börse seit zehn jahren
tag 0 5 7 365 like wenn du dieses bild
sehen kann ich finde mich herausfinden
wie viele leute meine bilder sehen
können denn instagram zeit nicht mehr
ein bein verloren meine bilder und das
ist jetzt mal so ein kleines experiment
wie viele das überhaupt sehen deswegen
nyc wenn du dieses beet sehen kann und
ist online liebe sonne so schön in der
sonne luca hölle los heute zu schneiden
aber ich habe eben nicht so wirklich
lust zu schneiden ich bin eher so der
typ der gerne dreht und schneiden es
nicht so mein ding und jetzt warten wir
auf die kommentare dann bin ich darauf
reagieren kann
diskriminiert durch alle blinden und ihr
wundert euch warum ich nicht auf alles
antworten nein das soll nur ein test
sein wie vielen leuten instagram meine
bilder zeigt sein vater ist keine ente
ist eine ganze ja das meinte ich auch
rente ente ganz was das eine qual mit
schlechten internet
alles zu beantworten hol dir cbd hasch
ist auch legal like könntest du
vielleicht meinen die hausgemachten
cupcakes von toolbox ausprobieren aber
bitte die eigenen kreation von max
diesen bier trinkt cupcake denen möchte
ich unbedingt machen das kann sich jetzt
schon mal an pisa diesen becken bier
springbreak cupcake aber ich muss eine
alternative für den bacon finden
deswegen marco geht von humor erinnerst
mich an open man kaum was man einmal
video zu drücken und schon ist man open
mind grinch like schlecht like wann es
allerdings doch gerne warum machst du
nicht mal ein gesangs video in einem
kloster und ich bemerke über allerhand
fanfaren von bei magic über drogen
kaffee mehr was abgeht like kannst du
mal bedienten hamburger die überhaupt
nicht so aussehen und mache nur die idee
shirt steht hier ausgezeichnet like der
anfang des videos like 2000 jahre später
das ist eine compilation danke schön
finde ich nicht mal waren es sogar dass
ich sie abonnieren musste danke gott
wir haben jetzt wieder 30 kommentare
nicht bei youtube lesen musste ich muss
jetzt weitere 7 kommentare beantworten
und eigentlich habe ich hunger dann ist
es zehn vor ich werde daraus die
bildschirmaufnahme an war sie aber ich
mache jetzt erst mal eine stunde pause
vom handy und werde essen und weiter
schneiden und dann werde ich in einer
stunde wieder kommentare beantworten und
auf sachen reagieren die meine zuschauer
mir schreiben zwischenstand bis jetzt
nicht wirklich viel zeit weg einfach
also ich muss auch die ganze zeit daran
denken dass ich das gleich wieder machen
muss das ist wirklich hängt einem sehr
im kopf aber jetzt wird erstmal weiter
geschnitten
[Musik]
erst dann negativ punkt und ließ so
lange mit in spa und so gebraucht habe
habe ich nur noch reis bekommen
der laden durch was zu essen wurde
hierbei studium keine soßen mehr haben
noch eins mit sicherheit gut vielleicht
liegt es nicht nur an instagram also
sich so viel zeit verbracht habe aber
ich habe auf jeden fall mehr zu tun als
sonst
[Musik]
ich kann sehen aber nichts riechen
komisch kommen wir zu youtube und ich
sehe aus wie ein hamster das sind wieder
so viele kommentare ich war früher als
kleines kind so sehr in den ziegen peter
verliebt warum hat er denn so ein süßes
gesicht
man sagt nicht böse wenn man es
ausspricht ist dass die leute ich kann
nicht immer alles richtig aussprechen
ich versuche es aber das ist auch so ein
ding wie können sich die leute mal
darüber aufregen dass man was falsch
ausspricht ist doch nicht schlimm für
einmal die deutsche sprache so
unterschiedlich ist je nach bundesland
und es eh niemals ohne gleich aussprache
von irgendwas gibt na ja wenn jetzt
schon wieder 30 neue bomben darauf ganz
ehrlich heute fällt mir das erste mal so
richtig auf wie viel feedback ich für
mein zuschauen kommen
[Musik]
bevor jetzt aufs vierte konzert gehen
kann muss ich auf jeden fall nochmal
meine nachrichten schicken denn ich
glaube ich habe viele kommentare
bekommen und sollte die davor
beantworten und nicht nach dem konzert
scheiße ich kann es sehen jetzt muss ich
es leid und bedanke denkt mega tolle
haare
[Musik]
ich bin gleich ein paar stunden auf dem
konzert was meint ihr was sich heute
abend noch alles beantworten so alles
gezeigt jetzt kann ich die jungs und
auch philipp poisel konzert wenn ja wir
müssen auf konzert
[Musik]
guten morgen der am gestern noch ganz
schön drastische wendung genommen weil
ich einfach mittendrin migräne bekommen
habe und dann sofort nach hause musste
mich übergeben habe und dann schlafen
gegangen bin ja und das war es dann mit
kommentare beantworten und auch sachen
reagieren sollten wir wirklich den
kompletten armen versaut aber so ist es
halt immer ein begriff hat das kennen
die leute wahrscheinlich da draußen ich
wollte jetzt nicht so durch die migräne
schummeln ich wollte an einem tag
ausprobieren aber das hat mich umgehauen
hat werde ich von gestern noch jetzt die
restlichen nachricht beantworten denn
das sollten wir wenigstens tun
[Musik]
gut das gespielt was zurückzugeben
okay ich habe alles von gestern
beantwortet und kommentiert und gelegt
und ich hoffe die migräne kommt nicht
zurück
[Applaus]
also ich hab mir gerade das video fertig
geschnitten und mir ist aufgefallen dass
ich mich verabschiedet habe also hier
nochmal per sprachnachricht schiedsleute
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
mein fazit wunder oh wunder ich würde
das nie wieder tun
versteht mich nicht falsch ich freue
mich wirklich welche jede nachricht
nicht bekomme und das ganze tolle
feedback von euch ich kann aber einfach
auf so wenig nur reagieren
manchmal bin ich in der laune dazu auf
vieles zu reagieren und manchmal habe
ich auch einfach tage wo ich das auch
alles lese aber halt nicht darauf
reagiere ich hoffe ihr versteht das und
würde sagen dass wir uns beim nächsten
mal wiedersehen tschüs abonnieren nicht
vergessen andere videos anschauen und
bis dann macht